well thank you very much even as he
refuses to concede
that he lost reelection to joe biden u.s
president donald trump gave a gift to
his first
national security adviser general
michael flynn
a pardon for flynn's crimes namely for
lying to federal investigators
about his contacts with the former
russian ambassador to the u.s
sergey kislyak flynn's case was part of
a legal black cloud
that hung over trump's entire presidency
flynn's son responded on the
conservative social media site
parlor thank you from the bottom of my
heart
president trump and a big middle finger
to judge emmett sullivan and trump's
ally
republican senator lindsey graham called
flynn a political victim
meantime democratic congressman adam
schiff blasted trump's decision
it's no surprise trump would go out as
he came in
crooked to the end earlier trump called
into a hearing
convened by pennsylvania republicans to
see whether
president-elect joe biden's victory can
be thrown out
this election was rigged and we can't
let that happen
we can't let it happen for our country
and this
election has to be turned around because
we won pennsylvania by a lot and we won
all of these swing states by a lot
anybody watching television
the night of the election was saying wow
i was called by
the biggest political people
congratulations sir on a big win
and all of a sudden ballots were dumped
all over the place and a lot of
horrible things happened newer bolder
more compassionate chapter
trump's complaints about politics a far
cry from the incoming administration's
call
for national unity and resilience on the
eve of the us's
secular holiday thanksgiving
vice president-elect kamala harris and
her husband visited a washington food
bank
while biden delivered a speech calling
on americans to find their resilience in
the face of the covet 19 pandemic
this is the moment where we need to
steal our spines
redouble our efforts and recommit
ourselves to the fight
let's remember we're all in this
together
joe biden's call for reconciliation and
unity
a marked contrast in both style and
substance
from that of donald trump rosalind
jordan
al jazeera the white house